y muchas promesas creíbles para unos y
muy insuficientes para otros la cumbre
climática empezó con un llamado urgente
a la acción los países más contaminantes
del mundo se comprometieron a reducir
sus emisiones con el fin de limitar el
calentamiento global a 1,5 grados
centígrados we are know that we are
sabemos que todavía estamos lejos de
donde debemos estar para decir con
confianza que alcanzaremos la meta de
1.5 grados a finales de siglo
más de 100 naciones se comprometieron a
terminar con la deforestación masiva
para 2030 los firmantes del pacto
representan el 85% de los bosques del
mundo entre ellos se destaca brasil
indonesia y la república democrática del
congo 90 países se comprometieron a
reducir en un 30% las emisiones de
metano para 2030 katz ucateba con
michelle y reducir las emisiones de
metano es una de las cosas más efectivas
que podemos hacer para reducir el
calentamiento global a corto plazo y
mantener 1.5 grados centígrados
en los debates de esta jornada las
naciones más ricas que no cumplieron con
el plazo para proporcionar 100 mil
millones de dólares sin financiamiento
climático a los países con menos
recursos dijeron que no cumplirán la
promesa hasta 2023 77 países se
comprometieron a eliminar el uso y
producción de carbón de forma gradual y
25 naciones acordaron dejar de financiar
combustibles fósiles en el extranjero
excepto rusia australia y japón los
jóvenes del mundo expresaron su
descontento en las calles en una de las
marchas en glasgow la activista
climática sueca greta schönberg no dudó
en decir que la cop 26 ha sido un
fracaso
manning la cop se ha convertido en un
evento de relaciones públicas donde los
líderes dicen hermosos discursos y
anuncian compromisos y objetivos
extravagantes
mientras que detrás de las cortinas los
gobiernos de los países del norte global
todavía se niegan a tomar cualquier
acción climática drástica
la segunda semana será la última
oportunidad para concretar acuerdos más
robustos que permitan cumplir con los
objetivos del acuerdo climático de parís
firmado en 2015